[Musik]
heute haben wir so eine wurst moped
gebaut
es ist irgendwie ein ostdeutsches
fabrikat da ist sind das heißt so ein
dreirad quasi das hat vorne zwei räder
und jetzt hinten zwei drittel nach vorne
zwei räder auf jeden fall insgesamt
raider wir händen den kasten abgebaut
haben einen neuen kasten draufgesetzt
die anschließend ich werde war ich ein
großer grill draufgekommen irgendwie das
eigentlich ein bierfass hat jemand
umgebaut und damit wollen wir auf
festivals rumfahren und grill
[Musik]
produzieren für funk und funktionen und
jugend formaten letztlich aber
gleichzeitig das hat auch irgendwie so
ein ort wo man sich ein bisschen selbst
verwirklichen kann hinter uns bauen
gerade ich weiß nicht 5 zirkuswagen
aufkommen wir hier ja ich weiss ich aber
noch sehen kann es wird langsam dunkel
die führen jetzt hier irgendwie morgen
im saal irgendwas auf und genau das das
klima das land sie kann jeder herkommen
wenn der platz braucht sie brauchten
platz
die bühne die wollten proben üben und
dafür ist dass da der matte ließ wir
haben
wir haben werkstätten und jeder kann ich
herkommen und das machen was er zu hause
machen
ich komme aus berlin ich bin gekommen
weil ich das schon sehr lange verfolge
und wir noch mal getroffen aber auf dem
festival und es gibt hier die
möglichkeit als freiwilliger helfer sich
zu bewerben das ja die wohnwagen zu
können kannst und ich arbeite viel im
büro nach online marketing und es zeit
fiel am telefon nur im büro sitzen und
ich mache auch gerne was in meinen
händen kommen können wir keine hobbys
oder weniger hohe preis hier vorbei
sondern es kann tatsächlich oft leute
vorbei wie irgendwas hat gut können
das ist voll bund kann jeder sein
also es gibt leute die so aus reichem
haus halt die mal irgendwie mal raus
wollen sich mal die finger schmutzig
machen möchten
das sind leute aus schlechten
familienverhältnissen die man raus
wollen um sich die finger schmutzig zu
machen also wirklich am ende ist immer
das gleiche scheiß egal wo du herkommst
egal wie du aussiehst egal was du
gemacht hast du noch nicht gemacht hast
du bist immer bekommen sodass ein
bisschen die message und deswegen kommt
dann auch jeder jede art von mensch
kommt so junge als er zugibt
[Musik]